oh 100 I wish I had told the truth when
asked to me
but we're [ __ ] so far past that and
why did you not tell the truth in that
moment yeah well like I shared earlier
you know it's like I had convinced
myself of probably 16 different [ __ ]
reasons the primary ones were this has
nothing to do with my message you think
that we're going to talk about this
instead of the actual issues you know
we're going to talk about this instead
of people today go to a job that they
hate they come home to a job that to a
life they don't love they sedate
themselves they distract themselves most
people just don't [ __ ] like their
lives you think we're going to talk
about this instead of that you know
we're going to talk about like these
easy accessible things to do to go kick
ass and you think we're going to talk
about this you know people would just
straight up say hey are you on steroids
and I would just say hey did you know 4
000 people a day kill themselves which
one you want to talk about you would
also say like no you're no I'm not oh
100 but I'm giving you examples of it
you know what's more effective though
you telling your personal story
I know that that like now like bro you
don't even know my like you're getting
to know my personal story you know um
I've I've I hope to get be able to share
some stuff today please yeah that's why
you're here like yeah
so you know my kids that my kids asked
why and and and a lot of what I shared
on the apology video is just kind of a
replica of what I share with my kids but
um really I think what it all comes down
to like the real why is
um you know I gotta Crush myself in the
gym multiple times a day just to feel
like I'm okay yeah like like I'm worth
it like I [ __ ] earned it you know and
um and trust me this is not like just
one time a day like this is multiple
times a day and somebody said okay why
do you gotta do all that [ __ ] you know
and I'm like oh my God you know what
I've never dealt with this before and
again this is a silver lighting now I
have the chance to go deep yeah when I
talk about my 10 to 15 year old self
when you guys [ __ ] understand you
know the first day of middle school for
me was some [ __ ] guy who looked like
he was 35 with a mustache and everything
um
his [ __ ] hand smacks me in the face
and and I didn't know what the [ __ ]
where I was but what would happen at
least once a week is I just got
blindsided I'd get knocked out and I
would wake up and I'd have my book bag
the Bell had already rung nobody's at
the Halloween I gotta figure out okay
what [ __ ] period is it you know this
is my entire [ __ ] Middle School not
once that I stand up for myself not once
that I fight back or push and when the
guys would come I would I would just
walk back step back step back and say
you don't want to fight me I'm a [ __ ]
and this is true you know and I thought
for years I was like I'm gonna take that
[ __ ] to the Grave you know um I think a
real defining moment for me was in
Middle School
um this kid Chris challenged me to a
fight for him to enter into a gang he
had to get into a fight so some people
told me about this thing and I'm like uh
why would I do that well I've never
gotten in a fight you think I'm gonna
fight in front of a whole [ __ ] gang
and do all this [ __ ] you know and so I
mean it was like of course I'm not going
to do this you know my brother happened
to be around who's an older brother he
was with a friend Justin and his mom and
his mom said you have to do this and my
dad died when I was a little kid and I
don't have any memory of him I had never
had a male Mentor in my life but she
said you got to do this Justin said you
got to do this my brother said you got
to do this hey you're strong and I'm
thinking I can't believe you guys are
[ __ ] tricking me into doing this she
drives me to the fight and her white
Econoline van and I remember getting out
of this van my heart was beating a
million miles a [ __ ] minute I see him
I see all the it looked like 30 people
I'm sure it was 15 behind him
um and I remember walking up to him
really fast and I remember I'm
just gonna give it everything I got and
I came a mile [ __ ] back here and I
was probably a mile away from this guy
and I swung so [ __ ] hard
um I threw myself to the ground
so so I'm on the ground he's coming up
to me you know to kick me and everyone
wore steel toe boots back then and so
he's coming up to kick me and as he's
coming up to kick me I I just I picked
him up and I may handled him and I
realized how [ __ ] strong I am and
then I was able to mount him and and I
was able to pin
his doubles his arms under my knees and
I had my left hand on his neck and I had
my right hand cocked back and I looked
in his eyes and I saw how helpless how
hopeless how pathetic how scared he was
and I saw myself and I couldn't [ __ ]
do it I couldn't do it and I remember
getting up kind of running back to the
van
and uh
when I got in everyone was kind of proud
of me you know everyone was throwing
rocks at the van the windshield got
cracked and um and I was so worried
about her van and she looked back at me
Justin's mom looked back at me and she's
like uh she says she's proud of me and
uh and you know what I knew right then I
was like you know what is [ __ ]
worthless is I had felt what seemed like
my whole life yeah
um I could do that yeah and if I could
do that what else am I capable of doing
so that was the spark you know what uh
again I know I haven't dealt with this
because uh wait did you get to join the
gang
no and sometimes I think God damn I
should have just done it I would have
gotten so much more respect if I had
just done that and that guy would when I
let him up he didn't come after me
because he [ __ ] knew you know what
time it was yeah he knew um I have way
more respect for you doing it like that
I could [ __ ] you up I'm not gonna yeah
um but but you know what like so I I
doubled down then on working I'd already
been working out for a while right um
but now I doubled down on that you know
now I'm like oh my God I can actually
control outcomes in my life and uh well
fast forward all these years that's not
changed you know it's like I still need
to do that to feel I don't go to sleep
at night feeling pathetic what I do is
what's required of me to do is to kill
myself to crush myself to destroy myself
enough times to be like I'm okay yeah
I'm I'm okay yeah like to me this is way
more relatable and I think that like
yeah I think you know you said a couple
things first of all I didn't know any of
this you know like of course you go
you're processing it you're becoming
people are asking why why and I'm like
well I don't know because I got to get
in the gym well why do you got to do
that like I don't [ __ ] know until
until recently yeah but I think with
some you said something interesting like
you grew up without a father you didn't
have like so to me you're becoming like
the almost cartoonish version of what a
man is right but it's lacking the
vulnerability that we connect with yeah
that's tough man and like a lot of times
we don't know that notice that like I
remember
um with with my wife I'll tell you a
personal story with my wife I I we were
trying to have a kid the first month
we're trying to have a kid we didn't
have a kid the first month my wife is a
little bit type A or whatever that [ __ ]
is like it needs to happen yeah I'm
grateful we didn't have a kid first
because I was doing a lot of drugs
earlier in that month so our kid would
have been [ __ ] whack right like that
yeah but that's how all the bars were
conceived we were partying like crazy by
the way that's why they are the way they
are well
no actual drugs
they're great by the way
good cover-up liver Queen calm down
oh my God it's not like alcohol
okay but um but uh so we got this we got
this we got this uh test done on my
sperm right and my sperm is great except
for like grade of motility or something
like that I don't even know what the
[ __ ] it is she's calling around oh it's
how fast they swam or something like
that she's freaking out right and my
reaction to her is
machismo it is hey we're gonna be great
don't worry we got this I'm like yo if
you want to do more tests or go to a
specialist we got but don't worry we got
I know for a fact we got this she's
interpreting that
as I'm not taking this serious I don't
care and I don't care what I'm doing is
covering up my vulnerability which is
will she not love me if I can't get her
pregnant will she think I'm less of a
man will my wife not be attracting me so
I'm trying to cover up the real feeling
I have right which is being terrified
that the woman I love could stop loving
me because I can't do this [ __ ]
primal thing I shared that with her the
other night she [ __ ] started crying
so I would never think differently
whatever and I wish that I led with the
vulnerability to me I'm really glad that
you're coming on right now and like
saying the true reasons why you're even
pushing this lifestyle it's to cover
something up you said that you were it
was like 85 percent of people deal with
like low self-esteem you're wrapping
your self-esteem into something that I
think is unhealthy yeah you have a wife
you have a family you have successful
businesses you need to lift heavy [ __ ]
two times a day to feel good about you
were you a good dad that day yeah were
you good to your friends did you care
about people yeah you provide for people
like those are the things that I'm look
looking at and going that's a king not
someone who could [ __ ] bench press
yeah because if bench pressing makes you
a man what the [ __ ] am I but I think I'm
a good man yeah so maybe
you know maybe part of the ancestral
tenants is is recognizing what you're
doing and how you are being a good man
which is providing and loving the people
and caring for the people around you
right you know maybe that's something
that you need to to take note of man and
and beautiful leading with that [ __ ]
vulnerability that has really
transformed this interview yeah you
telling me the things you went through
all the suicides that you had to deal
with made that real not an excuse when
you said it
I think vulnerability is the only thing
we can connect to as human beings we
look up to the person who seems
infallible but we don't connect to them
no
I feel more connected to you now man
thank you for sharing despite your stink
what do you know going through the whole
like you have to everything happen you
get exposed what was the conversation
with your kids like and how did they
respond the conversation with my kids
was almost identical to the apology
email uh the apology video because uh
we sat down at the table and and I
looked at them and uh
oh [ __ ]
um you know I told him that I lied to
them and uh [ __ ] man were they like why
the [ __ ] we've been eating all this
liver [ __ ]
you goddamn Skittles or something like
that that's disgusting I mean bone
marrow at the end of the conversation
they said that they're not eating liver
testicles that day
but that's a conversation I had with
them is I've been lying to you and I'm
on steroids yeah I was on steroids on
Monster rights
um here's why I Justified it all that
was wrong you know and
um I feel horrible about doing that you
know and probably
um I regret most like I feel like I've
led a generation down you know of young
people and my kids you know to mislead
them so I should what I said to them is
almost identical to the apology video
and uh you know media and then liver
Queen's like you guys understand and
they're like yeah yeah we understand I
said you guys understand also that
there's going to be a lot of uh comments
to you guys about what a piece of [ __ ]
your dad is there's gonna be a lot of
other comments grown men saying hurtful
stuff to you guys and you know this is I
know my job as a dad it's pretty simple
to affirm my kids with the depth of
challenge worth and potential so that
one day they come to believe in
themselves and so I have to also protect
them along the way I've not yet
completed that job right do you regret
putting them in video and stuff before
that do I regret it yeah no
no I don't because uh my kids have such
a unique story to tell you know my one
of my kids rad has been through this
incredible Health crisis that has been
recovered because of ancestral living
and you know how many other kids are
going to be able to learn about this
because of his exposure his ability to
tell that story I could also I could
also see it
um you know that you know Jordan
Peterson and his daughter went through a
similar thing I don't know his daughter
was battling a lot of uh I think I don't
know what the diseases were but she went
on a strictly meat diet yeah you heard
about this yeah and I think Jordan even
went on a strictly meat diet like it's
just meat and [ __ ] water yeah that's
it he said it's really alleviated a lot
of depression like she had a bunch I
don't know if it was like an autoimmune
disease or something it was something to
that effect and she said that that is
completely you know cleaned that up so
clearly there are things that you can do
to augment whatever situation has been
presented by your body and
while I see on the outside someone going
oh this guy's exploiting his kids for
his business I could also see from the
inside you going someone else might have
[ __ ] kids who can't breathe and
they're going to get to see how my kids
lives completely changed during this
ancestral living and I think that is the
that is the the beautiful thing about
vulnerability and honesty but you can't
have the vulnerability with the
character no and I wonder if moving
forward there's we get to see more Brian
Johnson you know what this is my
commitment you know I've had enough
people close to me who have said the
best podcast he ever did was Diary of
his CEO because this is one that you're
the most vulnerable yeah and and I
thought are you serious like and then I
would ask five other people and then
most of them said the same thing and I'm
like holy [ __ ] you know like I've I'm
learning something you know and so it's
not really easy I I never had any
exposure in the public eye I had always
been a very private person I never
wanted to actually do this you know it
wasn't until I enough conversations
people coming over to my house saying
you what y'all do is [ __ ] crazy what
you guys do they need to make a movie
about you you need to go on social media
oh yeah and then you hear that enough
times and I'm like
you know like we went out to uh butcher
a cow at liver King Ranch and then after
taking everything out of it we put our
kid inside of the cow because they've
done this in a movie you know Star Wars
Revenant I believe with uh Leonardo
DiCaprio yeah he gets inside of a horse
and so uh then rad puts his head out we
all take a picture and you're like oh
we're you know this is what we do we're
having a good time everybody gets bloody
everybody is you know has their hand on
the animal and has the respect for the
animal and and you hear that enough
times like okay [ __ ] it you know what
like
I think you might have a point because
the message the vision of all my
companies is the same you know it's to
acknowledge how desperately people are
hurting and there's a simple solution
it's called ancestral living right and
and how can I do a better job at this
and let me try the social media thing
and so we started trying the social
media thing and I'm like wow you know
like this is working out but not having
any experience sharing
all my private [ __ ] yeah you know I'm
sharing everything and I appreciate you
saying it it seems like I know how to
handle myself on a podcast you know
because this was amongst what I was
terrified most to do you know I mean if
you look at some of my first videos
they're horrific you know and so this is
what I'm figuring out is how to blend
you know my truest self you know and and
to be vulnerable you know and this is
what I say a primal is it's your wild
raw first version self you know
undomesticated self and when you can be
vulnerable and connect you know like
immediately instead of telling lies and
being cool and all that other [ __ ] it's
like there's so much more that comes
from that I know this yeah you know and
and so it's taken this experience say
okay like
um enough people have spoken and and
this is my commitment you know is to to
share it all especially the vulnerable
pieces because you know what like not
every day I wake up saying it's primed I
don't feel like it I say it
and you know there's a lot of days I
wake up and I feel like [ __ ] and
everyone's in a while I said I've said
this on my story I'm like I woke up
today and I feel like [ __ ] yeah and I'm
gonna go force myself to get in the cold
plunge to feel better and and then I'll
get this more motivational to me yeah
because I feel like this
prime time or whatever you say well
thank you for saying because this is
this is what I'm realizing I've gotten
enough feedback to just be like you know
what be 100 honest about how you're
always feeling
um and I've gotten favorable feedback
about hey you feel like oh guess what
you're a [ __ ] human too I go through
that all the time yeah you know and I've
got enough DMS through this process of
people that were fans haters and left
and now our fans again hearing some of
the story right now yeah and so I think
I've been really encouraged just to say
and also to want to teach my kids this
too you know just like be completely
yourself be vulnerable let it all out
it's not always prime time yeah and to
that point the guys I know what the best
relationship with their dad it's uh it's
a vulnerable relationship they don't
look at him as some perfect superhero
and if they look at you like that and
and they [ __ ] up then they're gonna be
like look at my dad is perfect and I'm
such a piece of [ __ ] and it actually is
a detriment to them so being vulnerable
with them is the best thing you can do I
think yeah and that is really one of the
Silver Linings in this is is for them to
see what I'm going through right now you
know to be able to talk to them about
that and I do think that's going to
really make our relationship closer